rule number one you dress like a
civilized well-groomed adult if you're
not that kind of adult then you need to
pretend that you will nobody stumbles
accidentally onto a plane you have to
book tickets you have to pack you have
to engage in some kind of planning ahead
of time so there's no excuse to not to
be completely dressed and showered and
presentable when you get on the plane if
I knocked on your door in the middle of
the night
well you probably call the cops but
let's say that you answered the door you
you'd be in your pajamas maybe wearing
slippers hair messy matted teeth not
brush blurry eyed you know unshowered
confused and I could not complain about
having to look at you in that disheveled
and disgusting State because I knocked
on your door in the middle of the night
but when I see you at the airport or on
a plane I did not knock on your door in
the middle of the night we are meeting
out in public and planned ahead of time
to be so I should not have to be exposed
to your middle of the night look I
should not have to see you in your
pajamas wearing slippers and a bathrobe
this is an airport it's not your bedroom